HTTP/2 brings
a lot of changes.
But how do we
transition from HTTP/1
to this amazing HTTP/2 world?
What do we have to do to
cater to all the users
out there in the
best possible manner?
With head of line blocking gone
in HTTP/2 and the new header
compression requests
are now cheap.
So things like concatenating
your JavaScript or CSS
are not necessary anymore.
And it can actually
make things worse.
Think about updating
a cached file.
If you fix a typo in
a JavaScript file,
like a missing curly brace,
you would force your users
to re-download the entire
concatenated blob of JavaScript
instead of just the fragment
that actually changed.
If each JavaScript
file was separate,
you would only invalidate the
cache for that single file.
Another advantage is the
new header compression
becoming more effective
the more requests are sent.
The more requests are sent, the
more headers can be re-used.
That means that having
multiple connections
to different servers is actually
bad for your performance.
That being said, minifying and
compressing your JavaScript CSS
and images is still a good idea.
A byte saved is a byte saved.
And especially in
developing countries,
that means saved money.
Additionally, all the advice
given for rendering performance
like deferring a JavaScript or
inlining styles is still valid.
And so is investing time
in building problem offline
support with service worker.
Most importantly, HTTP/2
is backwards compatible.
All servers that speak HTTP/2
will be able to speak HTTP/1.
A client that can't speak HTTP/2
will just fall back to HTTP/1
and keep working as before.
And those clients are
becoming exceedingly rare.
So don't be scared of
working with HTTP/2.
At the time of filming in early
2016, 71% of the web's traffic
had support for HTTP/2.
So it is fair to say
that you can optimize
your web for HTTP/2 without
paying much attention to HTTP/1
anymore as this
number will only grow.